New chat GPT 5.4 is insane.
Open AAI just leaked something they did
not want you to see. It's called GPT
5.4. And what this thing can do is going
to blow your mind. We are talking a
brain so big it can read entire books in
one go. Full picture understanding with
zero blur. An AI that can literally do
your work for you start to finish. This
changes everything. So here is what
happened. Somebody at OpenAI messed up.
They pushed code to GitHub, public
GitHub, and inside that code, clear as
day, was a reference to a model called
GPT 5.4, not GPT5, not GPT 5.3, a brand
new version that nobody was supposed to
know about yet. And then it happened
again twice in 5 days. Developers
spotted GPT 5.4 labels showing up in
internal model selectors and error logs.
Open AAI scrambled to delete everything,
but the internet never forgets.
Screenshots got saved. People started
digging and what they found is
absolutely wild. Let me start with the
biggest one, the context window. Right
now, GPT5 can handle about 400,000
tokens. That is already a lot. But GPT
5.4 is rumored to support 2 million
tokens. 2 million. Let me put that in
simple terms for you. A token is roughly
a piece of a word. So 2 million tokens
means this AI can hold an insane amount
of information in its head at one time.
We are talking entire books, huge code
projects, massive research papers, all
in one single conversation. No cutting
things up, no losing track of what you
said 10 minutes ago. No more of that
thing where chat GPT just forgets what
you told it three messages back. That
goldfish memory problem could be gone.
Think about what that means. If you run
a business, you could feed it your
entire website, every blog post, every
page, every piece of content you have
ever made, and it just holds all of it
at once and gives you answers based on
everything. That is a gamecher for SEO.
That is a gamecher for content. That is
a gamecher for literally anyone who uses
AI to get work done. Now, here is the
second big thing. Full resolution image
understanding. Right now, when you
upload a picture to chat GPT, it
compresses it. It shrinks it down, which
means it loses detail. Fine for casual
stuff, but terrible if you need
precision.
GPT 5.4 reportedly has a new setting
that lets it process images at full
resolution. No compression, no quality
loss. So imagine uploading a detailed
website design, a complex diagram, a
medical scan, a satellite image, and the
AI sees every single pixel exactly as
you see it. For anyone doing design
work, engineering, architecture, or even
just trying to get chat GPT to read a
screenshot properly, this is huge. No
more squinting AI. It can actually see
now. But wait, it gets even crazier. The
third leak is about autonomous
abilities, meaning GPT 5.4 for might be
able to do entire tasks on its own.
Start to finish multi-step stuff. Right
now, you have to kind of hold chat GPT's
hand. You give it step one, then step
two, then step three. With GPT 5.4, you
might be able to say, "Hey, go research
this topic. Write me a report, format
it, and send it." And it just does the
whole thing. Think about coding. You
could say, "Build me a landing page with
these features." And instead of giving
you one chunk of code and stopping, it
plans the whole thing out, writes every
file, tests it, and delivers a finished
product. That is not a chatbot anymore.
That is a digital employee. And look, I
am not making this up. This is straight
from the leaked code references and
developer analysis. Multiple sources
confirm these features showing up in
OpenAI's own systems. Hey, if we have
not met already, I am the digital avatar
of Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie Agency.
Whilst he is helping clients get more
leads and customers, I am here to help
you get the latest AI updates. Julian
Goldie reads every single comment, so
make sure you drop one below. Tell him
what feature you're most excited about.
Now, let me talk about why this matters
beyond just cool features because there
is a bigger picture here. The speed of
these updates is accelerating. We went
from GPT4 to GPT5 and that took a while.
Then GPT 5.3 came out and it was already
being used inside OpenAI codeex for
coding tasks. Now GPT 5.4 is showing up
in leaks just weeks later. The gap
between versions is shrinking. That
means the AI race is speeding up and if
you are not paying attention, you are
going to get left behind. Every business
owner, every marketer, every content
creator needs to understand what is
coming because your competitors will use
this stuff whether you do or not. Now,
here is the thing about the release
timeline. Multiple leaks suggest GPT 5.4
4 could drop as early as March or April
2026, which means it could literally be
any day now. No official confirmation
from OpenAI yet. No pricing details, no
benchmark results, but the evidence is
stacking up fast. When a company
accidentally leaks something twice in 5
days through public code, that usually
means it is close, very close. Now, if
you are watching this and thinking,
okay, this is amazing, but how do I
actually use AI like this to grow my
business? I want to tell you about
something. It is called the AI profit
boardroom. This is the best place to
learn how to scale your business, get
more customers, and save hundreds of
hours with AI automation. If you want to
know exactly how to use tools like GPT
5.4 for SEO, content creation, and
business growth the moment they drop,
this is where you need to be. Link is in
the description. Go check it out. All
right, let me keep going because there
is more to unpack here. The full
resolution vision thing opens up some
use cases that people are not even
thinking about yet. Think about
e-commerce
product photos. Right now, if you ask
Chat GPT to analyze a product image, it
is working with a compressed version.
Details get lost, colors shift, text on
packaging gets blurry. With full
resolution support, you could upload
your entire product catalog and get
accurate descriptions, alt text for SEO,
quality checks, all based on what the
images actually look like, not some
fuzzy version of them. For anyone doing
local SEO, think about this. You could
upload photos of a client's business,
storefront, interior, menu boards, and
the AI sees every detail, and it can
write descriptions that are actually
accurate. It can spot things in images
that the compressed version would miss
entirely. And the persistent memory
angle. Some of the leaked references
hint at cross session memory, meaning
GPT 5.4 might remember things between
conversations, not just within one chat,
but across multiple chats over time. So,
it actually learns your preferences,
your business context, your writing
style. You would not have to reexplain
everything every single time you start a
new conversation. It just knows. That is
a massive quality of life upgrade for
anyone who uses chat GBT daily. Now, let
me be real with you. These are leaks,
not official announcements. Things could
change. Features could get added or
removed before launch, but the pattern
is clear. Open AAI is pushing hard. The
context window is getting massive.
Vision is getting sharper. And autonomy
is getting real. Whether GPT 5.4 for
launches next week or next month. This
is where AI is going. And the people who
prepare now are the ones who win later.
So, here is what I want you to do.
First, smash that subscribe button if
you have not already. We cover every
single AI update the moment it drops so
you never miss a beat. Second, drop a
comment below telling Julian what
feature you are most hyped about. The 2
million token context window, the full
resolution vision, or the autonomous
task completion. He reads every single
comment. And if you want the full
process SOPs and over 100 AI use cases
like this one, join the AI success lab.
Link is in the comments and description.
You will get all the video notes from
there, plus access to our community of
38,000 members who are crushing it with
AI. And one more time, if you want to
actually use AI tools like GBT 5.4 to
automate your business, get more
customers, and save hundreds of hours,
join the AI profit boardroom. This is
where we break down exactly how to put
these tools to work for real business
results. Link in the description. Hey,
right, thanks for watching. Hit the like
and subscribe button and I will see you
in the next